hi everyone uh welcome to the Simons
Institute I'm aial I'm an assistant
professor at UC
berley uh for those of you who are not
familiar with the Simons Institute we
are the leading venue for collaborative
research in theoretical computer science
established in ER 2012 The Institute
brings together the world's leading
researchers in theoretical computer
science and related
fields I'd like to welcome you to the
workshop on logic and algebra for query
evaluations this is part of the program
on logic and algorithms for database
Fury and AI I'd like to thank the
organizers of the workshop for putting
together a great program there are
sudipa Roy Wolf Gang gbow Dano and Val
tannan so let me mention a few things
about logistics uh before we start so
food would be provided before the first
talk of each day and during the breaks
lunch is on your own but there are many
of good options around we ask that you
please leave the food and beverages
outside this
Auditorium and if you're looking for
storage there are lockers on the other
side of this
floor uh finally all talks will be live
streamed and and available later on the
website uh and our videographer orid far
will help speaker get set up uh before
for the
talk H finally I'd like to give special
thanks to the events team Ashley Freda
and lra for managing all the logistics
for this week's event and now I will
hand things over to sudipa we'll say h
to Dan to Dan will say a few more words
okay okay thank thanks tavisha and I'd
like to thank all the local organizers
for enabling this this Workshop so our
topic uh this week is extending queries
and logic with numeric computations and
more generally with computations over
abstract semi rings so this includes new
semantics for logic uh extensions of of
query languages with numerical
computations and lots of quite exciting
and surprising applications that all
from seem to need this extension of
logic with numerical computations so our
goal was not just to bring people
together which is always a good goal of
the workshop but we also think that we
there are several Divergent apparently
Divergent applications that can actually
benefit from a common framework and this
is our goal to discuss this common
framework that can benefit multiple
applications uh so the talks are
scheduled over five days um we have time
for discussions every day and for
discussing open problems think about
open problems and questions you might
have um and also I should also mention
that some of our speakers they really
wanted to come but they had to cancel at
the last minute because of events in
Israel so they will give talks online a
small number of talks will be online uh
okay on this note I'll give um I like to
introduce the first speaker Eric Kel who
will talk about new semantics for logic
based on samur rings so Eric please take
it
away
okay thank you very much for this
invitation I would like to talk about uh
semiring
semantics and this has its origins in
seuring province that started with the
semal work by Green karakis sanan a long
time ago
2007 and the basic idea of this approach
is to annotate the fact of a database by
values in some commutative semi ring and
to propagate these annotations through a
query keeping track of whether you use
information jointly or alternatively so
the idea is that the plus operation of
the semi ring interprets the alternative
use of information as for instance in
disjunctions and existential quantifiers
whereas multiplication interprets The
Joint use of information Junctions
Universal
quantifiers so the zero element of the
semi ring just stands for false and all
other elements provide some annotation
of true
facts when we Tak an information for
granted do not crack it any further we
interpret it usually by the one element
of the semi ring now the idea is that
with this approach you can get detailed
insight about which combinations of
atomic facts are responsible for the
truth of a statement and from this you
can derive additional information
beyond the truth just cost uh confidence
course access level number of successful
evaluation strategies and so
on so some words about semi ring when
you knew of you know of course what a
semi ring is uh but let us go through
some uh examples of those semi rings
that are relevant for this approach of
course the simple semi ring is the
Boolean semi ring the Boolean truth
value so in a sense we have always done
semi ring
semantics another important semi ring is
a semi ring of natural numbers that
which is important in U Back semantics
of
databases here it's mostly used for
counting object counting proof counting
evaluation strategies and so
on then a less well-known example is a
tropical semi ring overs the non-
negative reals together with infinity
where the operations are Min and plus so
the Min stands for the uh alternative
use of information plus stands for the
joint use information and this semi ring
is used in many fields in computer
science for for cost
computations there is another semi ring
that is in fact isomorphic to the
tropical semi ring the vapy semi ring
over seral interval between zero and one
where the operations are Max and times
and this is a saming that can be used
for instance for confidence course
although I find this interpretation
interpretation much less convincing than
the one of the tropical seuring for
costs then there is a large class of min
max semi rings so they're just induced
by some total order and then you take
Max and Min as the two semi ring uh
operations zero and one are the least
and largest elements so uh one example
is when you take the real interval
between Z and one this is often called
the fuzzy semi ring but there are also
finite minmar semi rings and uh one
particular example is so-called security
or access control semi ring where we
have an order of access levels like
inaccessible top secret secret
confidential and public and we use the
seing to reason about the access levels
to information that are necessary to
evaluate the
query and a more General class are catus
semi Rings Where are not uced by induced
by a total order but by a partial order
so it takes the infant soup as a same
ring operations and then there is from
the field of many valid logic we can
also take the Vash semi ring which can
be seen as an alternative semi ring to
reason about confidence core about
degrees of Truth where the uh addition
operations is against the max but the
multiplication is something a bit more
complicated and this semi ring is in
fact isomorphic to what I call the semi
ring of doubt the re reason about doubt
and uh where the plus operation is
minimization and uh the well the
interpretation of the joint use of
information is a truncated uh variant of
plus so your doubt increases when you
have uh use information jointly but it's
uh cut uh at at one the maximal
doubt uh so least
confidence now you saw that I was not
talking about Rings rings are of course
also semi rings but we are not
interested in rings we are interested in
semi- rings that are partially ordered
by
addition so you have this uh order here
a is smaller than b if a plus C equals B
for some C and this is always uh
reflexive and transitive but it's not
always antisymmetric so we require it to
be anti- symmetric so with this is Clues
Rings right we interested in partially
naturally ordered semi
rings so these semi rings can all be
called application semi Rings they give
you some particular information about
uh a logical statement or a query but
they do not answer the fundamental
question that I have uh mentioned at the
beginning so which combination of the
atomic facts are responsible for the
truth of a statement right and for these
we use another kind of semi ring so
called uh Provence semi rings and they
are in general semi rings of polinomial
so take a set of indeterminates and
these indeterminates are used to label
the facts that we want to track so we
associate it with an atomic fact an
indeterminate and then consider the
seuring of multivariate Po pols over
these indeterminates with coefficients
in the natural
numbers so this in fact is algebraically
this is a commutative seuring that is
freely generated by this set of
indeterminant and they have an important
Universal
Property uh which justifies to say that
this the most General semi ring for this
purpose namely any function from these
indeterminates into a particular semi
ring extends uniquely to a homomorphism
from this polinomial semi ring into the
semi ring s right and we can just think
of the homomorphism as the evaluation of
the given polinomial inside uh that semi
ring and the semi ring is a quite
complicated semi- ring so it gives a lot
of information that this information is
also a bit difficult to compute so there
are alternatives the alternatives are to
use some simple polinomial semi- ring
where you lose information with the hope
that this information is then easier to
compute and there are several possible
operations to simplify from this General
polinomial semi ring so one is that you
drop the coefficients right so in a
sense you are
not interested in so how many times you
can achieve something with with the same
atomic facts but it just suffices
whether you can do it or whether you
cannot do it so we just drop the
coefficients in the
polinomial an alternative simplication
simp ification is to drop the exponents
which corresponds to I'm not interested
how often I use a particular Atomic
Factor just interested in whether I use
it or whether I don't use it right and
so we just have
uh well binomials that are linear in
each variables or you can do both right
you can both drop the coefficient and
the exponent and then you get a sum of
monomials that are linear in each
argument and well you don't have any any
coefficients anymore besides these
dropping coefficients or dropping
exponents there is another operation
that is important in this context and
this is absorption absorption comes
corresponds to the observation that if
you have a logical statement P or p and
v then you can simplify this and just
take P right so P absorbs the uh the
conjunction and this is what we do also
so here so we absorb here and this means
that XY absorbs x² y because a monomial
always absorbs those monomials that have
larger exponents right so you simplify
uh this further right and you can do
apply this to this semi ring with
Boolean coefficients or you can uh apply
it to this semi ring here so soal the Y
semi ring and um so if you do both
operations you end up with just
irredundant uh so positive Boolean
operations so irredundant disjunctive uh
normal forms right so and for many
applications the seuring is is good
enough to compute what you want right
and it's of course you can it's easier
to handle right so this is as a general
picture of these polinomial semi
rings so um we will see um more in a
more detailed way what we can do with
this polom in a somewhat more general
setting that I want to introduce now
right so this approach of semi ring uh
Provence mapping logical statements to
semiring and deriving information from
that has been pursued quite long time in
database here and has been quite
successful right but for a long time it
has essentially been confined to
positive query languages right like
positive relational algebra unions of
conjunctive queries to a lesser extent
also data log okay um for data log you
need uh further conditions on the semi
ring and I will come to that later right
but all these posit query languages are
positive they do not involve negative
information they have no negation
operator and uh there have been
approaches uh to uh particular deal with
difference uh of relation soal monos
semi rings and so on but an evaluation
of valan I think back in 1915 or 16 was
that all these approaches are in some
sense unsatisfactory and diverge in many
Direction so the State of Affairs has
been considered um unsatisfactory right
and also the absence of an adequate
treatment of negation uh has been an
obstacle to to uh extend this approach
to other fields of logic in computer
science right one can argue that in
databases you can get quite far just
with positive
information there are limitations of
course but still you can get uh a long
way but I don't think this is true in
other fields right like in verification
or so I mean you you just need also
negative information and so to make a
Provence or a semi ring approach uh
successful also in other fields you need
a treatment uh of negation right and the
problem is that negation is incompatible
with the algebraic sem operation right
so and if in many scenarios this is not
just in provent this is also for
instance in team semantics right there
are people who know about that here
right negation is not really a logical
operation and this means of first if you
have uh a
formula uh Fe
right you have evaluated for instance in
in in a semi ring this doesn't give you
information what the negation what the
value of the negation of Fe is that you
cannot derive
the the meaning of the negation of Fe
just from the meaning of fee you need to
have to a closer look at the syntax of
fee in order to do that right I mean
it's clear if you interpret false as
zero and every other element of the uh
of of the sem ring as true then the
negation of a false statement you don't
know which degree of true is there right
you have to really look at a as a
formula in a in a closer way
so
what we what we
did uh has been largely triggered by a
decision of the staff of the Simon
Institute in the program of
2016 Nam they put valent me into the
same office right we previously we knew
of each other but we hadn't met so we
talked about what we're doing and uh Val
told about this problem of providing
um semi ring semantics or semi ring
Providence for full first order logic
with negation right and so we talked
about this and
[Music]
um what I had worked at that time mainly
on were infinite games or game theory
model checking games right and in model
checking games you also have a problem
with negation right uh because negation
in a in an evaluation game corresponds
to a role switch of the player what
previously has been the verifier becomes
the falsifier and vice versa and you
want to avoid role switches during
playing of the game it's very difficult
to reason about strategies if in the
middle of the game the player change
their roles right so what was one one
transforms when pushes the negation to
the atom one transforms this to negation
normal form so it's a question was does
this also work reasonably well in uh in
semiring semantics right it's not
obvious because you have these
polinomial right and uh have to deal
with that
so what we
came up with was a new approach uh to
deal with uh with negation well first is
negation is handled via transformation
to negation normal
form this also means that we need new
semi- rings of pols right that have two
kinds of indeterminant the positive one
and the negative one but of course there
must be a reasonable relationship
between a positive fact and its
Associated negative fact which means
that you have to move to some coo
semiring uh to deal with that and that's
it turns out that this Providence of for
logic is intimately connected to a
Providence analysis of game and the
negation is related to the antagonism
between the two players and in fact
Providence for game is of independent
interest and uh provides interesting
insights in strategies that you have in
a game far beyond the question who wins
the game that we will see this later
so there also this also leads to new
kinds of application so repairs missing
query answers but I'm not really talking
about that in in this
talk so well negation normal form what
does it mean so it means negation is
applied to Atomic formula only so the
formula negation normal form are just
obtained from uh the atomic fact their
negation uh via positive operation
disjunction conjunction and quantifiers
and of course an arbitrary formul
formula can efficiently be translated to
the negation noral form by a very simple
process using the demoran inequalities
and The Duality of quantifiers right so
once you have it in negation normal form
evaluation is a positive process
depending on positive and negative
Atomic
facts so this leads now to the notion of
a semi ring interpretation so fix a
commut ative semiring fix a finite
universe and a finite relational
vocabulary then you have the literals
over that universe and uh that
vocabulary they're all fully
instantiated uh atoms and negated atoms
and a semi ring interpretation for a
semi ring s is just a function mapping
these literals to values in the semi
ring right this can easily extend it by
evaluating equalities and inequalities
just by their truth value Zer and one
one which means we take the universe for
granted we do not track equalities and
inequalities right they are just
accepted as they
are now we call such a semi ring
interpretation model defining if it is
has a certain consistency properties on
the on the atoms and their negations
right so we say it's model defining if
for each such atom precisely one of the
values of the atom and its neg is zero
and if we have this condition then such
a semi- ring interpretation specifies a
unique structure namely those structure
where all the RS are true that have a
positive value right but we'll see not
only these interpretations are
interesting it is also interesting to
consider semi- ring interpretations that
are not model defining and that do not
Define a unique structure but a class of
structures so once we have this we
immediately get
uh a semi ring semantic for all first
order sentences right so we extend this
interpretation to evaluation of fully
instantiated first order sentence so we
denote this in this way this is a semi
ring value a sing valuation of the
sentence fee right and this just follows
the intuition that we have this Junction
corresponds to addition conjunction
corresponds to multiplication and of
course for the quantifier we just take
the sum or products over the elements of
the universe right so we assume here
that the Universe uh is finite
right but we can also do it with
infinite universes provided we have semi
Rings where we have reasonable
infinitary sum and product operations
this in fact Works in most of the same
rings that we had but it does not work
for instance in the natural numbers
right uh natural numbers you cannot have
infinite addition without going outside
the natural number so you have to extend
the semi ring by Infinity elements to to
make this work right so so in general
the approach works also for infinite
universes but you have to be a bit
careful uh which semi Rings you
use so I thought we also need new
polinomial semi Rings If we have this
right so the idea is now to annotate
atoms by indeterminist in a set X and
negated atoms in a other set X
bar with a
bje that relates every indeterminate
with a partner in the other set right so
that you have I mean you want to label a
specific atom by a positive uh
indeterminate and its negation by one so
with the association right and the semi
ring you consider it's a quotient semi
ring of the polinomial semi ring over
this uh full set of indeterminant right
so the quotient semi ring with respect
to the congruence that is generated by
the equations x and x * xar is zero
right so the this equation of course
means that a literal and its negation
cannot be true at the same time right
there their product is zero right so
this quotient semi ring Corr responds
just to
pols with the uh property that no
monomial may contain complimentary token
right these are all deleted because they
evaluate to zero right and of course for
for the
semiring uh n to the X we had a
universal property right do we have also
Universal Property uh in this setting
and the answer is yes we have but we
have to assume a stronger uh condition
right so any map from the indeterminant
into a semiring subject to the condition
that the value of x times the value of
xar is zero again uniquely extend to a
semi hering homomorphism from this uh
into
s so what can we do with it so
uh in I think in databases one often
argues about proof trees it's just so
approved tree and what is approved
approved tree is really uh an evaluation
tree uh that gives a positive value so
it gives you a process that whenever you
have say a
disjunction you just choose one of the
disjunct if you have an existential
quantifier you choose one of the
instantiations of that quantifier but if
you have a conjunction or a universal
quantifier you have to keep in your tree
all the possible children of that right
so it is a strategy in a sense how to
evaluate the given sentence right and
um so it's really the same as a strategy
in Associated evaluation game so if we
have such evolation trees we consider
for each literal Alpha the number of
leaves of the tree that are labeled by
that literal Alpha right and we the the
valuation of the tree is just the
product over all values of literals that
occur in the tree right so we can say
product over our literals the value of
the literal uh taken as often as it
occurs as a leaf in the tree and what is
a proof tree a proof tree is just an
evaluation tree that does not evaluate
to zero okay
and there's a general theorem that tells
you that for every semi ring
interpretation uh in particular semi
ring at every first order sentence the
valuation of the statement is the sum of
the valuation of its Tru
strees and when we now
look at this what it tells us in the
semur ring for dual indeterminant
polinomial we get the following right so
we consider a semi ring interpretation
into that
uh seg ring of dual in determinate
polinomial we assume it is model
defining that is if you map a literal to
something nonzero the opposing literal
has to be mapped to zero and vice versa
right and we assume that each literal is
either tracked that is it is mapped to
an indeterminate or it is not tracked
that is mapped to a truth value what
does the previous theorem then tell us
right or what does the Providence
polinomial of that sentence tell us
about the model checking problem whether
p is true in the structure that is
defined here right it tells us the
following right recall this is what we
had right the value of the sentence is
the sum of the valuations of its proof
trees but now the evaluations of proof
trees are monomials of that form right
so it tells us that this Pro provenant
polom is a sum of
monomials of the form well m is a
natural number and these are the
indeterminant and these are the
exponents so each such monomial tells us
there are precisely M proof
trees which use among trapped literals
only those that are labeled by X1 XK and
more precisely it uses the literal
labeled by x i or literals labeled by XI
precisely as many times as the exponent
tells you right
the untrack literals they may be used
arbitrarily right so it gives you a
precise description of the proof trees
that you have for evaluating your
statement so it answers that question
which combination of basic facts give
the trueu give the truth of the
statement and in fact in a very precise
way right it tells you all about the
evaluation strategies and what literals
they used so in particular particular if
you uh if you
evaluate
uh Atomic facts just by zero and one
then it will just count the number of
proof threes that you have right so and
of course in
particular a statement is true in the
structure defined by this uh by this
model defining interpretation if and
only if the polinomial is not the
zero so
is a pro tree of s the neg normal form
of s and Pi or what is a Formula that we
may assume to be a negation Norm the
form Pi is the semi ring interpretation
that's interpretation that in this case
defines a particular structure but gives
much more information about this
structure
right am I right that in for this
interpretation be model defining you
cannot map a literal to X and then
negation to xar is that correct one of
them has to be zero has to zero but uh
let's look at the next
slide so if you have uh as I said s
model defining interpretations are not
the only interesting uh interpretation
right so there are class what we call
model compatible interpretations right
so an interpretation is model compatible
if for every atom it either Maps the
atom and its negation to complementary
uh uh
indeterminates or it Maps them to zero
and one so it's just to their truth
values right so a model compatible
interpretation is consistent with at
least one structure on the universe but
in general with a larger set of
structures so we have those literals
that are evaluated ated to one so they
must be true in all models of the uh
interpretation and you have those
literals that are mapped to
indeterminates that can be true in some
models right and if we now have
evaluation of a first order sentence
with respect to such an interpretation
then this Providence polom describes
those proof trees whose leaves are in
must or May right so it must be true or
they may be true
right so every monomial corresponds to
one proof tree and gives precise
information about the literals on which
this proof threee depends right so it
gives a complete descriptions of all
models of the sentence that are
compatible with the given
interpretation
right so that's a more general setting
of
that okay so this is uh basically what
we did when we
met some years ago at a Simon's
Institute to develop uh this Theory now
meanwhile we have become a bit more
ambitious so so what the goal really is
to the develop semi ring semantics as a
general theory that does not just apply
in to first order logic does not just
apply in this database setting but it as
a general logical Theory right and there
are a number of research programs that
are say associated with that some of
which I want to talk about the second
part of my talk now and well one program
is to to push this Beyond first order
logic right in fact we want to have a
semi- ring semantics as a general
approach dealing with any kind of logic
right for some Logics this is
straightforward completely trivial but
for others it's not uh straightforward
and particularly it's not
straightforward for logic with fix point
I mean I'm come from finite model Theory
and infinite game so I'm mostly
interested in these Logics right uh but
of course there are many Logics that go
beyond first order logic by some kind of
recursion or unbounded iteration
mechanism right all these Logics and
verification for instance so we want
semi ring semantics be useful for all
that then you want to analyze game right
so these basic and since first uto
soring valuations you can view do them
as a strategy analysis of the model
checking games for first a logic and
these are just a cyclic reachability
games right games on trees basically or
play games on dags
right but
uh with there is a
generalization which we'll talk about
later with Omega continuous semi Rings
where you
have required that whenever you have an
ascending chain it has converts to
supremum that is compatible with a semi
ring operations and these are the sem
ring that are uh that work for things
like data log or so and in the game
theoretic setting this works for
reachability games that may possibly
have Cycles right but it does not extend
to games with more complicated winning
conditions such as spooky Games parody
games or just said games with incomplete
information right those the question can
we also provide a semi- ring based
strategy analysis for such games what do
you mean by your strategy analysis you
will see uh a result that tells you what
I information about all the available
strategies in some class for a given
player um and the third is well once you
have extended this to many Logics the
question is do the usual theorems and
tools that we have in logic also work in
semiring semantics and this is not
trivial right I mean going to sem
semantic May destroy many things we know
in logic so to what extent to classical
result of Logics generalized to semi
ring semantics and how does this depend
on the properties of the semi ring right
most in most cases it work for some semi
rings and it does not work for others
right so let me talk about these three
there of course many other points right
so it's what should develop a proof
theory for this as well and so on right
but there these are things where we
already have some results so fix Point
logic right so semi ring Antics has
meanwhile been extended to many other
logic and the most interesting
challenges are when you have fixed
points and of course for a particular
fixo logic namely data lock this has
been done a long time ago already the
first paper by green karakis and tanan
it has been done for data log and there
has been a more detailed analysis some
years later uh that also gave a circuit
evaluation uh for for dat we right and
this is based on Omega continuous semi
ring that is a semi ring basically a
semi ring where least fixed points exist
right uh so Universal ones are no longer
semi rings of pols they are semi ring of
formal power series which just means
potentially infinite sums of
monomials and with dual
indeterminant which we can add not just
to polinomial semi rings but also to
semi rings of formal power Series this
pushes this somewhat further it provides
a semi- ring semantics for semi-positive
data log that is data log where the
input predicates can also be negated but
not the uh computed
predicates and for what we call the
positive fragment of least fix Point
logic that is a fragment where you can
build fixed points but you can all only
build uh least fixed point that not
greatest fix point you cannot negate
least fix point right
um so however in the general fix point
Logics and also in the modal me calculus
you may have arbitrary interleavings
between least and greatest fix points or
between V negation at least fix point
and the Omega continuous semi rings are
not adequate for these right you you
can't do it with Omega continuous semi
rings so the question is what are the
algebraic conditions that are required
when you have this larger settings right
you have to impose some additional
conditions on your s ring and there are
basically two conditions one is full
continuity is quite obvious observation
you don't have just ascending change
have to a prum but also descending
change need to have an infimum and this
must be compatible with the semi- ring
operations right and this condition
already suffices to get a well- defined
semantics for both least and greatest
fix point but it is not yet really a
meaningful semantic in the sense that it
tells you something relevant about the
Sens maybe pathological semantics to to
make it really work we need the
additional condition that has also been
well known before and used in many
settings that is that the semiring
should be absorptive now there this is a
law of absorption that we already had in
this simplification of the polinomial
semi Rings right um so it says that a
product AB is absorbed by a for any AB
right but the important uh consequence
of this or in fact an equivalent
characterization uh of this in in
naturally ordered semi ring is that
multiplication is decreasing right and
this should be the case right when you
have uh because it means for instance
that the conjunction has in sense a
smaller value than the conjunction right
it should p and v should be less true
than than P right and this is this is
true in all these absorptive semi rings
but it's of course not true in the semi
ring of natural numbers where where
multiplication increase so in a sense we
throw away semi ring of natural numbers
when we impose this right and so what
we we an analyze this and it shows that
indeed absorb the fully chain continuous
seuring uh fully continuous seuring I
should have written uh each monotone
function has at least fix point and the
great fix Point greatest fix point and
this gives a meaningful semantic for
least fix Point
logic can you explain why do you need
absorption because masteri will give you
that if the functions are monotone there
is always a list on the greatest fix
points so yes but it will not be um
uh in a sense the dualities between
least and greatest fix points will no
will no longer
survive that's a negation of a least so
yeah so so you have I mean you're just
uh you you can divide a sem Define a
semantic but it will not give you very
reasonable information about about the
formula and
um so the question is do say such sem
Rings exist right and they do in fact
most of these application semi Rings uh
like the tropical semi ring therapy sem
ring in MA Sam ring ltis Sam ring Lucas
evich Sam ring they all have these
properties but Sam rings that do not
have these properties are these General
Sam Rings like so Sam rings of pols uh
uh over the natural numbers semi Rings
uh of uh formal power series and so on
so the question is are there also is
there also notion of the most General
semi rings for fix Point logic in this
setting and there is and these are the
semi ring of generalized absorptive
pols what are saying no the polinomial
have this form so what are the features
you don't have coefficients right so the
natural numbers are thrown away way they
cause problem so we just have Boolean
coefficients the exponents on the other
side may also be infinite so you have an
in Infinity as a potential
exponent and you have absorption among
monomial so if you have a monomial and
another one that has for each variable a
larger uh exponent then the one with
larger uh exponents is absorbed right
and a consequence of this is that there
is no longer a different notion between
pols and formal power theories because
you can say such
a a polinomial is an anti-chain of
monomials with respect to the notion of
absorption and these antichains are
always finite so every formal power
series is in fact already a polinomial
right so you you don't need this
distinction which simplifies uh things a
lot of course you can do as again when
we have this we can add the Dual in
determinance which we need when we want
to interpret also negative fact and uh
these have universality properties that
indeed makes them the right General semi
rings for fix Point logic yes so you
have infity
X only either can be or each monomial
yes yes but a different mon
it's okay yeah but in in the same
monomial if if you have both they will
cancel
out yeah yeah yeah yes
okay if I if I care about this F Point
logical Finance
structions then I have we have
complementation theorem one application
of Le fix points there is a price we
have to increase the why is it this
satisfactory in which case you only use
Omega continuous semi
rings to give semantics I I realize
doesn't work for model logic because the
increase inity but what about this fix
point right well I mean this increase of
theity it's uh it's a very complicated
process right I mean you need a stage
comparison theorem that uh that's exp
expressible yes but at a price right and
uh um what is the
problem we're looking here at the
philosoph behind what searings do I need
to give seing to my logic and of course
it's very nice to go what you you've
done with
a fully continuous absorption but to me
if I just want to stick with Omega
continuous you can do it but I mean it's
it's when you when you do this
transformation is not clear what you
lose right I mean this is this is a
Boolean transformation right and it's
not clear that it uh that it preserves
the seic property looked at if it
preserves I don't think
so you know that I mean it does not
preserve the semantics it can't because
uh if you have greatest fix points then
we can express something like x to the
infinity we cannot get this from a least
point I mean okay we should
take also I think the transformation
will probably change the way the formula
works and so it will change the provence
information
so let me see uh a look at uh an area
where this
uh can be put to use right so we in fact
with these fully continuous and
absorptive soring we can provide a
strategy analysis for more complicated
games than than reachability in
particular for Bui
games and uh the core of such analysis
are what we call sum of strategies
theorem right so to have such a sum of
strategies theorem we need some
ingredients right so we need an
appropriate semur ring that is based on
the labeling of moves by
indeterminant we need evaluation of game
positions now often we do this in the
following way right so we we look takes
a fix point formula that tells you this
position is a winning position it
belongs to the winning region and we
Prov and we look at its sem ring
valuation right and we have an
appropriate class of strategies usually
we cannot take all strategies but we can
take all usually we also don't take just
the positional strategies we take a
slightly larger class right and you have
to do this for different games
separately so let's look at bushie games
what is a bushie game this is they're
infinite games where one player wins if
uh he can hit a good position infinitely
often some good position infinitely
often right
and this is in a sense the simplest
class of games that
are not just interesting but really
really
interesting uh in this setting because
uh they requir the formula describ that
this is a winning position requires an
alternation between greatest and least
fix points so it's not the least fix
Point process to to say this right Eric
quick Interruption so maybe um many
people maybe myself we don't know what a
Bui game is is it with k bubles or no a
Buie game is a a game played on a game
graph right and the winning condition is
not just that you have reach reach some
good position but you have to reach some
good position infinitely often and how
many papers are are
there yeah or or you just move one one
through the
graph you move through the graph right
happen in you players construct an
infinite path through the graph and the
first player wins if uh a good position
is hit infinitely often right so it's
let's
say the step when you have reachability
games and safety games so the step
immediately after is are buy games right
I mean I see that Aon has acceptance
condition that looks very much like this
but two players could could reach a good
position infinitely often no see so we
just have we I mean it's it's a zero sum
game in the sense one player wants to
reach uh a good position infinitely
often and the other player wants to
avoid that so the other player has what
we call a Kobi condition but they could
both re reach their condition their goal
no no uh every play reaches either a
good position infinitely often or just
fine or not reaches no position uh but
it could switch between a good and a bad
position infin the off it's not a
problem so so the other player that
plays against the first player is not
trying to get that bad position
infinitely often no he is trying to
avoid that the good position is seen
infinitely
often so the other player I mean you can
look other games as well right but this
is a game where one player has a buy and
the other kop the same KOB
condition so the appropriate strategies
here are
something that we call absorption
dominant which is rightly more General
than the positional strategies a
positional strategy just means whenever
you reach the same position again you do
the same move yeah here you don't have
to have this but uh
um you minimize in a sense not the set
of moves that you use but the multi set
of moves you you cannot remove any
occurrence of a move without losing uh
the property that you win right and now
in this case a sum of strategies theorem
tells you that if we have such a guy
game and such a an interpretation into
some absorbed if not fully continuous
seuring then uh well the valuation of
the position is the same as the
sum of the valuations of the absorption
dominant winning uh strategies you see
the analogy to the result about proof
trees right but is now it's a more
general setting where your strategies
are not just say finite proof trees
right but you have strategies that work
in some infinite games but it's B same
basic idea and if we look at this not
just for not for buy games but for I
cyclic reachability game we get back the
other
result so you ask what you can do what
is a strategy analysis so here is what
the strategy analysis uh tells you so
from this
polinomial uh that describes in a sense
all ABB dominant strategies you can
derive many things right the player zero
wins if and only if this polinomial is a
nonzero polom so then that is a winning
position you can get the edge profiles
that is which Edge are used and how
often are they used for each of these
absorption dominant strategies and since
you can easily when you look at such a
strategy easily decide whether it is a
positional strategy or not you also get
the number and shapes of all positional
strategies and you can answer other
questions you can answer the question
whether a player can still win if some
subsets of the move is forbidden right
so these are taken away right Deutsche
band has taken away connections can you
still reach your uh probably you can't
right so but it tells it to you
right
um You can also do repairs right
so just very
uh very sketchy so assume that the
player loses from a position right which
will mean that
uh your polinomial is zero so the
question is what are the minimal
modification of the game that make a
player win so
which moves can you add or or delete
right and this can now determine by a
semi ring valuation in this tool in the
DET terminate variant right taking into
account the sets that you are allowed to
add or the moves that you are allowed to
delete right and the polinomial keeps
precisely track of the possibilities so
each binomial will tell you a
possibility to repair your game so that
you win 10 minutes or yeah
okay
and this is not just limited to tracking
edges you can also consider other kinds
of of of changing the game EV tracks a
winning condition right so you look how
can you change the winning condition so
I make set down this position now
becomes a good position can I win then
right uh so of course what has to
develop this uh in more details but in
principle it's possible to do repairs as
it is possible to do repairs for
database queries in in in the classical
uh
setting respect to the term polom of the
natural numbers right of course the
question is
about can you compute these things
really right Matias will talk about uh
possibilities of computation in uh
algorithms in this setting of
uh of absorptive semi Rings um you can
compute them it's efficient with respect
to the number of operations that to use
compared to the size of the object that
you compute but the problem is that in
general you have an exponential number
of such strategies and you have an
exponential number of minimal repairs so
to make it practical you have to limit
the a number of objects that you really
want to track right if you have only
small uh po potential changes then you
can do it but in general uh you're
solving here an exponential problem and
you can't avoid this
okay so in the remaining uh little time
uh let me address the third thing so to
what extent do classical result of
Logics generalize to semi ring semantics
so so far we looked at four different
such topics one is Elementary
equivalence versus isomorphism so and
you have finite structure then
Elementary equivalence and isomorphism
are the same because every finite
structure can be atiz by a first or
sentence that is not true for infinite
structures in general but a finite
structure you can precisely describe
right a trivial fact right um Z1 loss
every first uto sentence is either
almost surely true or almost foolish
true on random structures right famous
Z1 law by gal and Fagan from the 60s and
70s right thir thing locality yeah
serums of hump and Gman tell you that
first order logic can only Express local
properties and in fact every for first
of the formula is equivalent to one what
called Gman normal
form last thing Aon FR games provide a
sound and complete method for
establishing logical inequalities now it
turns out that all the definitions that
we use in these observations the
definitions generalized to to semi- ring
semantics in a relatively
straightforward way some sometimes you
have to to POS some restriction but this
works but what about the results right
this is not at all clear that the
results survive for semi
rings and for fact for elementary
equivalent versus isomorphism they in
general don't they only do in some cases
right so what is situation right both
Elementary equivalence and isomorphism
generalize right so Elementary
equivalence means that every formula
gets the same semi ring value in both
semi ring interpretation
right so what before was a property of
two structures now a property of two
semi ring interpretations right so
Elementary equivalence has its natural
counter part and so does isomorphism you
have a bje that preserves every right so
in Boolean semantics for finite
structure these are the same but this
fails in semi ring semantics in fact
there exist very simple uh semi Rings A
Min Mar semi ring with three elements
weall semi ring Min Mark sem ring with
two elements is just the Boolean semi
ring so going One Step Beyond gives you
a semi ring where this no longer
survives and in fact which is a so
finite SE Rings interpretations are not
always first order definable up to
isomorphism right this is because the
formini cannot really access the semi
ring value so you in
general it's not possible or it's not
always possible to interpret such a semi
ring interpretation up to
isomorphism sometimes you can but if you
can do it you canot the infer can do it
with a finite set of axium sometimes you
require infinitely many axium and even
weirder even if you can do it finitely
many axioms you cannot necessarily do
with a single sentence that classically
if you have a finite atiz in logic it
just takes the conjunction of the atoms
you have atiz by a single sentence this
does not work here because you cannot
get back necessarily the value of the
conjunct when you you know the value of
the conjunctions right so but there are
other semi- Rings where it works so the
results here are a certain partial
classification of the semi ring where
this holds and where this does not
hold Z1 law random structures also
generalize to what we may call a random
uh semiring interpretation right just
fix a probability distribution on the
nonzero element of the sa ring that
those that correspond to
true then for each
atom uh over a given Universe make a
random choice that TOS a coin where the
literal is true or its negation we want
model defining interpretations here and
then randomly assign a semi ring value
uh to the true literal according to the
chosen probability distribution right so
this getes a notion of a random semi
ring
interpretation as a question does the Z1
L generalize and it generalizes for many
semi rings in a quite interesting
way
namely with probabilities converging to
one exponentially
fast the valuation of Any Given sentence
almost surely concentrates on one
specific semi- ring
value so this means really as you have
in classical logical partition of of
first order logic into the sentences
that are almost surely false and those
that are almost surely true you have
here a partition into the sentences that
almost surely evaluate to particular
semi ring value J and J but so the
interesting thing is that this
partition uh collapses so for most of
the semi ring values there are no
sentences that evaluate this values the
only things that survive are the value
zero the value one and the smallest
positive value so if you have maxing is
the smallest if you have ltis saming it
is the infimum of the positive ones
right so you have a uh every sentence
almost surely evaluates just one uh of
these three
values and when you say for many semi
Rings this means that you have
identified particular semi
Rings a
classify okay I mean a here of course a
bit so I mean it it definitely worked
for muring it always works for latis
seuring and it works in a different way
for a natural samine right uh I mean
we'll have to to state it differently
but there is let's say an analogous
result that works also for the natural
semi ring there are also results on
absorptive semi rings
but quite so for many semi Rings uh you
can do the analysis of course it
requires you method requires that you
describe uh form by certain kind of
polinomial
or or other algebraic expression
so um how much time do I have should I
stop two
minutes okay so let me uh to say
something about locality so classically
there are two kind of locality theorems
in logic there is H theorem there is
Gman theorem H theorem gives you
localities Criterion for M equivalent of
two
structures uh based on the number of
well substr local substructure of a
certain isomorphism type up to a certain
threshold right so it's I don't want to
State it precisely it just gives uh such
a Criterion for M equivalence that is
indistinguishably up to quantifier
ranking as the Gan normal form theorem
says that every first order the formula
is equivalent to a Boolean combination
of local formula and the particular of
sentence that Express there exist 17
disjoint uh structures of substructures
of radius r with a certain property
right and in sem ring
semantics we say that this theorem of H
generalizes but it only generalizes to
fully itm potent semi rings that is semi
rings that both addition and
multiplication are IDM potent right S
Plus s equal s s * s equals s
right once you have this condition then
the classical proof survives but if you
don't have it it does not survive more
interesting is Skyman here formul with
free variables do never have GMA normal
forms if you don't have the Boolean
seuring for
sentences the Gan serum also fails in
certain semi Rings such as the natural
number and the tropical semi ring but
and this is the main positive result we
have GMA normal forms over minak samur
rings and latis sem
right so and in fact we also have
results on a games but for reason of
times I will not State this so what all
these
analysis tell us is that well for
certain semi Rings it works and for
other semi Rings it doesn't depending on
the question you ask and the intuition
is that well we have a certain hierarchy
when we go from the Boolean semi ring to
Wi ma semi ring many things work when we
go to ltis semi rings still many things
work when you go to absorptive semi
Rings fewer things work but you still
have a chance when you go to the Natural
semi ring everything breaks down almost
everything breaks down right and of
course there are many other um say
logical questions that you can ask and
particular you can ask is there a
reasonable proof theory for this right
and I think the only chance uh where
this may work is in absorptive semi
Rings right because you need the fact
that multiplication is decreasing right
right uh but uh in a sense we do not
have this yet right but there are a
number of such logical questions that we
pursue and the goal is to make semi ring
semantic really uh well consistent uh
and uh usable Theory uh that works in in
many
scenarios thank
you okay so um we don't have much time
but I I think we should still take one
or two
questions from the audience I don't have
a question so um so your premise is an
asymmetry between falsehood which can
only be zero and Truth which can have
various
degrees uh what happens if you drop this
asymmetry if you allow multiple degrees
of falsehood not just zero but other
values of the semi ring and the same for
true but I
mean this has been done for a long time
in multivalued logics like multivalued
logic is of course just this approach
you have many truth values right you
have a different shades of uh of truth
right so you want interpret things like
possible and and so on so uh for
instance lucich logic right you have all
these or in fuzzy logic right you have
different degrees of truth um and there
are many results about that right I
think really uh it is important that the
intuition here is is different right
uh I mean the intuition here is not that
the values are some shade of truth but
there are Tru that is annotated in some
way right and if you want to annotate
also falsehood then I would do a
different approach then I would uh
proceed as following I would interpret
it any formula not by one semi- ring
value but by two semi ring values one
for the formula itself and one for its
negation right so to have to to regain
the Symmetry right uh we have let's say
come up with definitions for that but we
have not really done any serious work on
that right but I think it's it's really
important that the that semiring
Provence has a different intuition or
different goal to start with than let's
say many Valu Logics as they have been
pursued in many decades of of logical
studies got it okay I I really think we
should stop here and go for coffee a
quick high level question which might
not make sense U so searings have had
you know enormous success with these
sort of languages like data law can can
you comment on any work for Say ding
complete language um prolog or
ion we haven't we
done okay so Eric will be around we can
talk to him over coffee so let's thank
him thank
him